como muchos países el reino unido- se
está preparando para un invierno marcado
por la variante omicron el director
médico de inglaterra advirtió que el
número de casos seguirá batiendo récords
después de que gran bretaña registrará
más de 78.000 nuevas infecciones el
miércoles
me temo que habrá un número creciente de
pacientes con omicron que ingresarán en
el sistema nacional de salud en el
hospital en cuidados intensivos y las
proporciones exactas aún no las
conocemos pero habrá un número
considerable en respuesta al aumento de
los casos de omicron en reino unido
francia dijo que prohibiría los viajes
no esenciales al país a partir del
sábado los viajeros que lleguen a
territorio francés también tendrán que
someterse a una prueba de pcr 24 horas
antes de la entrada en lugar de 48 esto
significa que limitaremos los motivos
que permiten a los viajeros entrar desde
reino unido a francia esto se limitará a
los ciudadanos y residentes franceses y
sus familias y todo esto tiene que ver
con el turismo y los viajes de negocios
para las personas que no son ciudadanos
franceses ni europeos las personas que
no son residentes franceses obviamente
estarán limitadas
al otro lado del atlántico canadá
desaconsejó a sus ciudadanos en los
viajes internacionales no esenciales y
dijo que introduciría más medidas de
salud pública el jueves indonesia
informó su primer caso de oakland en una
persona que no había viajado
recientemente al extranjero la
organización mundial de la salud dice
que es probable que la nueva variante ya
esté presente en la mayoría de los
países